foreign
kicks off this hour in Charlotte North
Carolina Natalie welcome to the show
hello thank you for having me absolutely
how can we help
well first of all I'm going to just say
right off the rip that my husband and I
have separate finances
basically due to on my end there's some
narcissistic Tendencies over there some
emotional abuse we've been together
about six seven years
um so we are separate there we do have
an emergency fund we're on baby steps
four five and six
and we have some cash
um at home hidden and some in the bank
obviously and
so I found out um after some kind of
bigger fight that he's been taking from
the emergency fund without my me knowing
and
um I thought I could trust him so I've
honestly never thought to count it and
come to find out he's been spending that
as cash and keeping money in his account
for himself so I've never been so close
honestly with that and some of the
emotional abuse
um I've never been so close to
considering separation I've offered
um counseling as an option and that is
not an option
um so he said no to council he will
refuse it he refuses yes doesn't believe
in it so now I'm kind of to the point
he's written me this long letter and
talked to me about it but I'm kind of
in a pinch of can I get someone like
that to ever change or basically
um so I just kind of accept things as
they are he's admitted to everything
after I had to find out he likes to lie
but I find stuff out and then he admits
to it then and agrees that I'm wrong he
hasn't blown up since but I'm kind of in
this spot where I don't know if I should
give up the hope that he's going to
change or not that it makes it any
better or any worse but how much money
are we talking about
um five grand and this was sitting in
the emergency fund in the bank
this is at home so this was part of our
use five thousand dollars in cash
without you knowing
correct what did he use that money on
certainly just daily expense
what do you think what do you think he
what do you think he used the money on
personal
personal uh
I guess habits bad habits is there a
addiction
okay marijuana okay
um
I'm sorry that this is happening this
sucks
it's really hard when you know marriage
is is two folks involved and it's really
really hard when one of the people is
trying and offering counseling and hey
let's work together and the other person
is like I'm out like they've tapped out
and uh
I hate that it sounds but it sounds like
to me like he's tapped out like if you
if you're not willing to do counseling
you're not willing to yeah I mean you
gotta he's got to take a step forward I
mean it sounds like you're taking 10
steps forward and he's kind of taking
one step back going away from you and I
hate that that's happening
um
my in these situations I'm always like
okay let's let's get in counseling or
let's get in let you know let's find a
good church community and get around
some folks who can encourage us and help
us out but it kind of sounds like he's
just said no to all that is he depressed
um and that's the thing and he told me
that he has been struggling with
depression for the past couple years
um and I've tried to talk to him about
that before because his dad brought it
up to me and um he
is not an emotional person so he won't
talk to me about it so yeah and that's
kind of where that and we have uh little
kids together I don't know where
um where to go how many kids you have
three
is he willing to get medical help see a
psychologist a psychiatrist what is he
willing to do at this point no church no
counseling
um basically marijuana his uh weight
handles that's his advice do you have
Community Natalie are there folks around
you do you have family friends a church
do you have people that you can lean on
and really count on
I do and I have some friends that I can
count on
um some my the thing is people have been
around since the beginning and they are
a little biased at this point yeah
um so I'm gonna I'm gonna take a page
out of John's book I'm not I have no
therapy background no degree background
nothing like that this is just Jade Jade
warshaw talking and we're talking as
buddies right now you're not in a safe
environment
you've got somebody who's using drugs
regularly you can't trust them they're
gaslighting you and you've got kids
involved and for me that's it I Sam this
is not Sam warshaw but if Sam if I found
myself in this situation with Sam worsha
I'd I'd be hitting the road I'd be
getting out of that situation I'm not
saying that that means you're getting a
divorce right away but I am getting out
of that house and I am getting my kids
to a place that is safe that there's no
drug use involved that there is no uh my
guess is there's probably some other bad
habits at play here as well and into a
physically safe and mentally safe
environment and I'm glad that you've got
some folks around you is there anybody
that you can hang with for a while while
you kind of get your act together
financially and figure out what that
next step is
yes there is I guess the only thing that
scares me is um
I know my my mental health is already at
stake but
my mental health my kids are very little
yeah
so
that's the only thing really
um honestly can you and you're just
afraid you're just afraid you won't be
able to kind of take care of them on
your own
I can do it um it's mostly just being
living with somebody else and trying to
I guess get along that way financially
and then
um honestly it's just the part I came
from separated parents and I made a vows
so that's where I'm struggling and I
don't know well I think nothing else you
need to get counseling for yourself even
if he's not willing just so that you
understand how to move forward with this
but letting it just sit and fester or
not do anything about it is about the
worst thing we can do here for you and
the kids and for him
if he needs to hit rock bottom to get
his life together yep
to speed this process up I want this
marriage to work and I still believe
there is hope but we got to get him to a
point where he's angry at the situation
where he goes I got to be there for my
kids yeah and you can't control that
Natalie we hope that that happens but
ultimately you're not in control of that
what you're in control of is you making
a plan what does that look like for you
to to get safe what does that look for
you to get healthy if it's counseling
what do you need to be able to do
financially start tonight get in your
journal and start writing out a
financial plan a mental plan and even a
locational plan for how you can make
this work
um for for your family I hope you guys
do are able to reconcile and you've got
to get people around you you can't do
this alone it's just simply too hard so
if you need to find a church community
in your area do that if you need to find
friends that can come around you do that
but this is this is going to take a lot
of time to just rebuild the trust even
if this is going to work but marriage
isn't 50 50. it's 100 100 man this guy's
giving you zero right now and that is an
unsustainable option we're praying for
you this is the Ramsay show